uh there's been so much about
officer michelonis he went out of state
for a while for rehab and
trying through his recovery he's back
here now but still is in rehab and his
family is so grateful for everyone who's
who's really donated to fundraising and
stuff for his for his help and he was
involved in the hockey community here in
las vegas played a little bit i actually
asked about the game yesterday i played
hockey myself and i asked some of the
fellas i was playing with hey what's the
deal with the game for officer shea you
know are we all taking part and he's
like actually it's uh like former junior
and college players and some golden
knights and some silver knights and unl
so it's like top level stuff so
out of my league so actually will be a
pretty competitive game actually well
you could go you could just ride the
pine i'm definitely i was definitely
riding the bench sitting there filling
the water bottle oh opening the door
there you go
i got you another stick yeah so it
should be i'm looking forward to i might
check it out myself you can be the puck
boy the puck boy yes
yes retrieve the puck
john langler's new title i'm going to
put that boy yeah
puck boy as long as you're supporting
the cause absolutely and it is a great
cause
fantastic yes